[Music]
foreign
dragons is that classic hero's journey
you've got a ragtag group of Misfits
Where we have to fight dragons and evil
wizards in order to save the world why
do we pull that off uh figure it out
over a drink probably best
it's about finding your own hero within
and each character has their own version
of that Journey oh got him now is it
exactly that you bring for this I'm a
planner I make plans I will not be
complicit in the illicit use the bill
Gotham booty can someone else right next
to this guy I think as a wicked sense of
humor through this and that allows us to
have as much fun with this as we can
I'm glad he's on our side the nuances
that each individual actor brings is
what makes this film so great
this I give you now trusting that you
are protected with your very life
I will
hold this
I'm part of the ruthless sand of Thieves
but he's not as evil as a red Wizard
never put your trust in a con man
The Dungeons and Dragons World has
amazing creatures in this one I think
they outdid themselves
these creatures are the same you really
can tell they put a lot into this what
is that again now we're back
[Music]
this is just big fun movie making
it's a great adventure with characters
that you're going to care about we want
to give them the movie that they've been
hoping for that's what I've been saying
it's pretty badass
[Music]
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
and when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we help the wrong person steal the wrong
thing
does it mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need to get a fighting chance
we're gonna need strength you got this
right I know you don't
say we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's now there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made the plant so the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not relevant
thank you
[Music]